[Music]
I've just been told this is special that
a very important member of the TBS
family wants to drop by to say hello
so once again please welcome the founder
of TBS mr. Ted Turner
[Applause]
[Music]
your role mr. mr. Turner as always we
are honored to have you here
shut your mouth cone man with an e we do
here TBS now stands for total
okay it's not cool I don't think that's
okay ever since I bought this network
from a toddler and in Atlanta gun
convention it's been the crown jewel of
basic cable and I will not sit here and
let perfection be destroyed by some
freckled covered blister with hair it's
a terrible thing to say
Albert Nobbs Albert Nobbs what the hell
Oh what yeah
let me explain Glenn Close played a
woman dressed as a man in the movie
Albert Nobbs
and she looks exactly like
hey funny on this show for once somebody
call Ripley's Believe It or Not alright
that's pretty low mr. churner why are
you here well I stopped by because I
heard a certain American treasure is
celebrating a birthday today well I you
know what that is very flattering I
don't consider myself an American
treasure it's not you you beady-eyed
for hire talking about Kourtney
Kardashian yes that is a fact Courtney
and I do share a birthday yeah today
Courtney turns 33 which is 112 in
Armenian years she'll be celebrating by
having the Army Corps of Engineers waxer
up early okay
that is sir that's harsh she's a demon
temptress
she broke the heart of my dear Teddy
Junior look at him he's still devastated
all right let me try and follow you here
you're saying that Kourtney Kardashian
once dated your fake Buffalo well why
not
he's just hollow and fake is she I'm
sorry no wonder my audience is buying in
to your hate tonight oh these drooling
coco zombies the only thing they care
about is beer bonging a gluten-free
speedball then it's off to be
wait-listed at DeVry their freighters
about dating one of the pet shop boy
okay wait a minute
Pet Shop Boys you are so out of touch
your cabbage all oh what's that Teddy
Junior I knew she'd come crawling back
Conan Kenny jr. just got a booty text
from none other than Kourtney Kardashian
she likes it buffalo style no I'm proud
to tell you I don't know what you mean
it's when a large animal covered in fur
goes at it with a buffalo oh God
quiet your silence what would it go in
all seriousness what I wanna wish you a
very happy burger silence yeah Wyatt
your silence became silent and I was
late on the quiet okay and I all right
got flustered
there we go yes sir in all seriousness I
want to wish you a very happy birthday
well well thank you that's that's very
nice Teddy jr. and I even got you a
present I have it right here present
that's fantastic right here that's great
[Music]
Turner
[Applause]